Hi, I'm Christa Brelsford.
I'm a Liane Russell Fellow at Oak Ridge National
Lab.
I've always had an idealistic bent and I can't
think of a better way to spend my career than
trying to understand, prevent, and mitigate
what I see as the biggest risk to our global
society: climate change.
I grew up in rural Alaska in a small village
of 83 people, not far from the villages that
are producing America's first climate refugees
as climate change-driven coastal erosion literally
wipes their villages off the map.
I then spent a decade living here in the desert
Southwest where allocation institutions that
were appropriate for last century's problems
are now creating a situation where one more
drought might cause major social and economic
upheaval.
These are complicated hydrological and environmental
systems, but the problems we face because
of changes in these physical systems will
only be solved through interventions in human
social structures: our laws, policies, and
behaviors.
We cannot understand the complex and interdependent
world that we live in without developing theoretical
and empirical models that acknowledge the
role of human social structures, choices,
and behaviors.